[Music]
all right joining us now is Missouri
Senator Eric Schmidt
Senator what is your message tonight I
know you've heard dribs and drabs of
what's in this uh bill that they have
been negotiating supposedly for four
months but what's your message to your
Senate colleagues tonight trying to sell
this this thing is a mess first of all
Joe Biden has every Authority needs
right now we shouldn't be negotiating
with a guy who has no interest in
securing the Border it'd be like
negotiating with Bernie maid off uh to
secure your life savings and invest it
wisely run away it's not their DNA cuz
here's the tale of the tape he reversed
remain in Mexico he ended that he's PID
he paid contractors 140
$140,000 a day to not construct the wall
he's abusing parole and he sued Texas
who's actually tried to secure the
Border he has no interest in it and the
idea that he's going to double pinky
swear and really promise next time with
some new language to do it is ridiculous
it's based on a false premise also
secondly we shouldn't be normalizing the
idea that 5,000 people coming here
illegally is okay if you're under that
if you're over that all of a sudden we
have a problem we have a problem right
now third of all this is a rushed as you
know as you pointed out Laura we haven't
seen the text all we know is the stuff
that's been leaked it is offensive not
just to Senators who are going to
presumably vote on this but to the
American people that you would be
selling this without showing it it's
being negotiated in a dark room in the
back in the back room CH it's already
already yeah I think it's
Scher Laura yeah the other thing is
Schumer's going to close debate on this
probably Thursday think about that for
this thing that's so complex that every
word changes that senators are going to
have like a day to look at this thing
it's totally ridiculous this thing is
not necessary to secure the border under
existing law Trump closed the Border we
had a secure border Joe Biden could do
it today he just doesn't want to you
know you know how we know that this was
a sham from the beginning and really a
political move to try to you know turn
the tables on Republicans or help Biden
is because they didn't involve the house
speaker in any of these talks like if
they were really serious they would have
brought Johnson in and said look this is
what we're thinking about it would allow
this this and this it wouldn't allow and
they would have sat down with them they
didn't do that but I bet my bottom
dollar that Schumer involved hakee Jeff
Jeff in some way shape or form in these
talks you agree with me on that I do
agree with that and and uh speaker
Johnson was very clear today that this
thing is DOA so here's my hope is that
we've been told that it would take a
majority of the minority meaning you
maybe need 25 Republicans to vote for
this so my hope is that that people will
see this turd for what it is not vote
for it because it's DOA in the house why
in the world will we go through this
when Joe Biden has existing Authority we
should be beating up on him for the 9
million people that he is allowed to
come here illegally it's as simple as
that so this is a this is a Fool's
errand and exercise and futil
because we can have a secure secure
border if you actually had a president
interested in executing the law yeah
they won't do town halls in their home
States on this border bill I can tell
you that um a Daily Caller exclusive on
this terrorist who made his way to
Minnesota who crossed our border Federal
authorities um finally have have have
seized him but they allowed him to enter
the country he roam freely for nearly a
year he's a Somali member of al-shabab
and this was a internal Federal memo
that the Daily Caller news Foundation
got its hands on but they let him slip
through and he went right to Minnesota
of course where there's a there's a very
large Somali Community um in in
Minnesota it's always been a concern of
of many people that you know allowing U
El shabab members to come into the
country and an open border uh could be
real
problem yeah we don't know who these
people are Laura or where they're at
many people are being paroled which by
the way is supposed to be individual Jud
educations but Biden is illegally using
that by the way one of the things he's
doing wrong for entire classes of people
or certain countries with court dates
sometimes in the 2030s I mean this is a
total abuse of our system but this is
what happens when you have a bunch of
open borders Global Citizens running the
White House in the United States of
America so we ought to hold firm tell
Biden to enforce the law and not by the
way one thing to look out for here Laura
2 is there could be language in here
that that hamstrings a future president
president Trump's ability to actually do
the things he did before but again
nobody's seen it so it's just a joke
yeah well um Senator you've been a
leader on this thank you so much great
to see you tonight hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else